from Nick hi Michael I am almost
embarrassed to ask but I need your
advice on something I've always felt
like I had a secret something I needed
to hide from my family and close friends
I've known this about myself for some
time but was afraid to act on my
impulses I think
tulsi gabbard is a total smoke show
whose appearance is second only to
Aphrodite and truthfully after one beer
it would probably be a tie I'm tempted
to give in to my more primitive desires
and support her politically however
she's a total Lib what should I do
say profound question Nick do not give
in oh this is a tale as old as time my
friend do not give in simply because
you've fallen a little bit gaga for an
admittedly very beautiful politician
particularly in comparison to her
colleagues who are generally speaking
physically less than beautiful now the
thing I will say for Tulsi she's got
some kind of interesting ideas she
breaks ranks with the Democrats on a
number of I don't even want to say
issues so much as premises or angles of
her world view so if you want to fall in
politics with Tulsi Gabbard do so for
her vision of the world and for her
policy stances do not do so for her
physical beauty the physical beauty will
fade my friend but her voting record
will be forever
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description